before their hit movie came out in 2014
Marvel's guardians of the galaxy were
obscure comic characters known only to
hardcore fans now Groot Drax and rocket
raccoon or household names but what many
fans may not know is that some of the
characters underwent drastic changes in
the transition to the big screen so hold
on to your robot legs because here's
what the guardians of the galaxy are
really like the team the movie depicts
the meeting and initial team-up of the
guardians of the galaxy star-lord Rocket
Raccoon Groot Gomorrah and Drax the
destroyer but when the original
guardians of the galaxy team debuted an
issue of Marvel superheroes in 1969 none
of those characters were present instead
the guardians consisted a guys named
Vance Astro Martin X Charlie 27 and
yondu the only one who made it into the
first movie and not even as a member of
the team Rocket Raccoon in the comics
Rocket Raccoon looks pretty much the
same but he has a totally different
backstory instead of a soldier of
fortune with a tree sidekick rocket
originally was the sheriff on a planet
designated as an insane asylum it was in
that capacity that he was introduced to
Marvel readers when the Incredible Hulk
accidentally ended up on his planet that
incident gave rocket the only sidekick
even less articulate than root
you're Groot in a movie full of
memorable lines Groot has perhaps the
most memorable so what it's pretty much
all I can say but in his earliest Comics
appearances Groot spoke often and with
much foreboding in tales to astonish
number 13 he visited earth to warn
humanity that it's doomed declaring
himself the ruler of Planet X and
turning a forest into his own army
nearly 50 years later Groot was
reintroduced in a way that was much
closer to the lovable giant you see on
screen if this is on the Giant in comics
he's off and closer to 25 feet tall Drax
portrayed by the almost inhuman leaf fit
MMA fighter Dave Bautista Drax is a
violence machine who doesn't understand
the nuance of language and is singularly
focused on one goal avenging the death
of his family who were killed by Ronan
the accuser in the comics his origin is
similar except it was Thanos who killed
both Drax himself and his family before
Drax was resurrected by Thanos his own
dad in order to exact revenge plus he
often rocked a cape purple pants and at
the door of a little swim cap wouldn't
it be great to see him put that outfit
on in a sequel
yondu in the comics yondu was a noble
alien archer who came from the future in
an alternate timeline in the movies he's
still got the arrow but now he's ditched
the fantasy threads and gone for a
decidedly more utilitarian look he's
also now a rough-around-the-edges
intergalactic pirate who uses a magic
arrow to steal pillage and kill if you
think that makes him sound like a blue
kind of evil Hawkeye you're not entirely
wrong but yondu's arrow is different
because it responds to his commands when
he whistles which is you know pretty
cool Peter quill the movie version of
Peter quill is equal parts thief pirate
and salvager all of which is a far cry
from his original style in the comics a
square-jawed law-abiding space cop with
a skin-tight unitard though now that
effect a leader of the Guardians he
didn't appear in the comics until 1976
seven years after the guardians of the
galaxy debuted but as in the movie he
once did serve time and the prison known
as the kill although in the comics he
was locked up alongside none other than
fan OHS Kimura rescued by Thanos after
aliens killed her entire race and
trained to become the ultimate assassin
Tamara's tragic backstory from the
comics was made even more tragic by
director James Gunn because it's Thanos
himself who murders her family in the
film version Whaley invaded my favorite
daughter
but gun did go a long way to empower
Gomorrah in another way
redesigning zoe saldana x' costume so
she looks more like a powerful warrior
rather than the typical comic-book
swimsuit model Ronan the accuser he's a
deeply chilling hammer wielding villain
bent on victory at any cost in the
guardians of galaxy movie but in the
comics he's a bit more complicated
not to mention jacked up the supreme
accuser the Kree Empire Ronan is a
career military man fighting wars and
delivering judgment according to a
strict internal moral code how complex
is he not only is he fought alongside
Marvel heroes at times
star-lord actually once served as his
military advisor and more importantly
his dance partner dance-off bro me
versus you it's on
[Music]
nebula karen gillan
the actress cast to play nebula actually
fares a bit of a resemblance to the
nebula of the comics - the blue skin of
course that's why it's a little weird
that the filmmakers made her bald to
play the role there are other
differences too in the movie nebula is a
loyal servant of Ronan the accuser but
in the comics she's fought alongside
Gamora and against both Ronan and Bannos
flesh she doesn't share Professor X's
hairline so there's fat koreff in both
the comics and the movie Korath is gruff
intense and focused on the task at hand
war combat and destruction as a sidekick
in the movie though we don't really get
to see much more of him including the
fact that in the comics he's actually a
brilliant scientist instead we mostly
have to judge him by his cool fashion
makeover gone or the goofy hat and blue
skin of his comic book look in favor of
Djimon Hounsou and futuristic barrettes
and spooky contact lenses the collector
Benicio del Toro makes brief appearances
in Thor the dark world and guardians of
the galaxy is the mysterious collector
while the scenes are played mostly for
comedy they also set up Marvel's
franchise wide Infinity stones plotline
see there's a reason he's collecting
everything cool in the universe to
protect them from Thanos he's kind of
like Noah Noah's Ark he believes that
there's gonna be a big catastrophe in
the galaxy in the whole universe and
he's collecting all these
preaches to preserve them somehow acting
on that need to preserve the collector
even tried to collect the Avengers in
the comics one thing he collected when
he went from page to screen a bit of a
better fashion sense I mean look at this
guy
yikes Thanos Thanos pretty much looks
exactly the same in the movies as he did
in the comics which is like a sinister
wad of great bubble young with teeth and
guardians of the galaxy gamora's desire
to stop her adopted father is a major
reason why the team is looking to
protect and retrieve the Infinity stone
but while he's still a genocide Elias in
the comics he's also a better dad he
even given Gamora nice Christmases when
she was a little kid with the tree
presents the whole shebang he may be
trying to destroy all life in the
universe but at least he's into hands-on
parenting that's the spirit you will do
it yourself it's tough being a single
dad you guys thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you think of the changes
Marvel made to pick guardians of the
galaxy
[Music]